Hi.
My name is Chris
B. I'm a developer
advocate on the
Google Cast team.
In this episode of
DevBytes, I'm going
to cover some of the essentials
of creating a Cast web sender
app that runs in Chrome.
Currently, the Google Cast
SDK is available for three
platforms-- Chrome,
Android, and iOS.
In this video, I will
focus exclusively
on the SDK for Chrome.
In order to build a Google
Cast web sender application,
you will lead to install
the Google Chrome
browser and the Google
Cast Chrome extension.
If you already have
Chrome installed,
make sure you are on
version 32 or higher.
To get the Cast extension, visit
the Google Chrome Web Store
and search for Google Cast.
The Cast extension
is what allows
web senders to communicate
with Cast receivers.
With Chrome installed and the
Cast extension ready to go,
let's take a peek at the Cast
sender life-cycle for a moment.
Once a Cast sender
application has been loaded,
the app will detect and
initialize the Cast APIs,
get notified about
available receivers,
connect to a receiver, and
begin exchanging messages
over the established connection.
Closing up the life
cycle is disconnection
from a receiver device.
Let's take a closer look at
each phase of life cycle.
Chrome sender applications
are constructed
using HTML, JavaScript, and CSS.
Sender apps can be hosted
locally during development
and then move to production
servers when publishing.
A Google hosted Cast sender
JavaScript resource provides
the API that your sender
application uses to communicate
with the Cast
extension, which manages
the interaction
with Cast receivers.
A Chrome sender application
must detect and initialize
the Cast API before
communicating
with the Cast receiver.
Prior to using the Cast APIs,
the web sender application
needs to first check
that they're available.
This is accomplished by
looking for the existence
of chrome.cast
JavaScript namespace
and checking the
chrome.cast.isAvailable Boolean
flag.
Depending on how the web
sender application loads
its resources, it may need
to set up a retry timeout
to detect the Cast APIs.
With the detection
out of the way,
the web sender
application is now
ready to initialize
the Cast API.
Initialization connects the web
sender to the Cast extension
and lets the extension know that
the web app is Cast enabled.
Performing the
initialization consists
of creating a sender
request object that
holds the application ID of
the receiver that will launch.
Then, constructing a
new API config object,
which takes the session request
object as well as a session
listener and receiver
listener callbacks.
Lastly, the web sender calls the
chrome.cast.initialize function
and provides the API
config object along
with the success
and error callback.
When the success
callback is invoked,
the web application
has successfully
initialized the Cast APIs.
However, there is one more
thing that the application
needs to wait on
before proceeding.
Looking at the API
config constructor,
the receiverListener passed
in performs an important role
in the discovery Cast devices.
Cast web sender applications
delegate the management
of available Cast receiver
devices to the Cast extension.
The API config that
the app creates
is passed along to
the Cast extension.
And the receiverListener
is invoked.
The receiverListener is
passed a string parameter
that should be checked
for the available value.
Any other value
should be treated
as no receiver
devices available.
The receiverListener
will be invoked whenever
there is a change in the
availability of receiver
devices.
The web sender should
display the Cast icon
when the
receiverListener reports
Cast receivers are available.
Now that the
application knows when
to show a Cast icon
to the user, we
can explore how to request
a session on a Cast receiver
device.
It is actually quite simple.
The sender can call on
chrome.cast.requestSession
and provide a success
and error callback.
The success callback will
be passed a Cast session
object that can be decorated
with update listeners.
The success callback is
dependent on user action
and may not be invoked.
Let's take a look.
Use the receiverListener
as a way
to determine if the web
sender application should
show the Cast icon to the user.
When the user clicks
the Cast icon,
the Cast extension will show a
list of available Cast receiver
devices that can be
connected to by the sender.
If the user closes the list
without selecting a device,
the request session error
callback will be invoked.
Otherwise, if the user selects
a Cast receiver device,
then the extension
will communicate
with the Cast receiver to set
up the communication channel.
Once complete, the success
callback of the request session
function will be invoked.
With a connection established,
the sender application
may now communicate with
the connected Cast receiver
application.
Messages are exchanged between
the sender and receiver using
namespaces, also
called protocols.
These messages are used
to invoke behaviors
on the receiver application
and to update the sender
application as to the
state of the receiver app.
One example of
message exchange would
be to load some media
onto the Cast receiver.
The Cast APIs come bundled
with a media API that
enables a sender app to tell the
receiver to load and playback
media, such as video.
In this case, the
media info object
gets created that bundles
information about the media.
This object is then used
to create a load request
object that gets passed to
a session function called
load media.
The load media
function serializes
the data and communicates
with the receiver application
over the media namespace.
Sender and receiver
applications must
agree on the
supported namespaces
in order to communicate
with each other.
The last part of life
cycle is the disconnection
from a receiver.
When a session is
first established,
the session app is
passed a session object.
Adding an update listener
to the session object
allows the sender app to know
when a session has ended.
The session listener function
is passed a Boolean value.
If this value is false,
then there is no connection.
The user can
initiate a disconnect
by clicking the Cast extension
and choosing stop casting.
This will trigger a
session update listener
when the session is torn down.
And there you have it, the life
cycle of a Cast web sender.
We're very excited to see what
you build with Google Cast.
To get you going,
we're providing
a number of resources.
You can discover more about the
details of the Google Cast SDK
at developers.google.com/cast.
The design checklist will
go a long way in guiding you
down the path to creating great
second screen applications.
You can find sample Cast
sender and receiver apps
at github.com/googlecast.
Use Stack Overflow for
questions and comments.
Tag them with google-cast.
In future DevBytes,
we will dive deeper
into the Cast sender
SDK for each platform
and the Cast receiver SDK.
Join the Google Cast developer
community on Google+ for pro
tips and share your experiences.
It's now up to you to go out and
create great Chrome web sender
applications.
Happy casting.